vienen a mis espaldas si quieren saber
cómo se vive son ríos de gente que están
caminando por esta Avenida a la nueve de
Julio nada de las principales granas
grandes aven
idas en Boca en el obelisco en el centro
epicentro de Buenos Aires están yendo
para allí yo venía por otra Avenida otra
de las principales avenidas Santa Fe
hacia aquí ríos de gente también
esto que mencionaba Juan pupiales antes
de lo que veía en Qatar de la hinchada
Argentina haciendo tan grande quieren
saber de dónde sale de aquí de esta
gente que está aquí en mis espaldas
marchando para celebrar en el obelisco
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires de verdad
es multitudinaria esta marcha de
celebración marcha como no he visto en
los últimos meses y años en Argentina y
además una marcha unificada con una
causa común y una causa de felicidad